[Music]
the other nugget in there was
confirmation really from don garber that
vegas is going to have an mlst yeah but
i don't think anyone's really surprised
oh not a shock indeed you'll hear from
the commissioner from in just a moment
here but let's first check out the
reason why they're excited about las
vegas nice crowd for what really amounts
to an exhibition game the league's cup
final league amex kicking it with
seattle there are a lot of leon fans
there the sounders were probably less so
but scoreless in the first half now to
the second seattle they do score but
they won't be celebrating for longest
club leon scores three times in the
second half to walk off with a 3-2 win
mexico celebrates a victory but who's
really celebrating las vegas here's the
commissioner of the mls
well vegas we hope will have a team
whether it's by 2023 i don't know but
look at this i mean this is this is an
exhibition game we got a great crowd we
had a gold cup final here that's sold
out this is a great sports market it's
going to be a great soccer market and a
great mls market